et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec une ag avait rachète chef du
service de réanimation cardiaque qui est
directeur médical de l'hôpital richaud
oui chu à beyrouth n'est jamais rachète
de bonjour et merci d'être en direct
avec nous depuis le liban ce matin leur
première question quelle est la
situation actuellement dans votre
hôpital aujourd'hui bonjour d'abord
merci de nous recevoir à votre antenne
la situation à l'hôpital du manège et
avait identifié le disait l'autre nos
collègues tout à l'heure où il ya une
fuite des médecins du liban des hôpitaux
centraux des hôpitaux universitaires
principalement la fuite est aussi grave
sur le plan qualitatif que quantitatif
nombre de médecins sont partis et pas
encore tous les jours nous avons eu des
demandes de tester à faire date et
stations médical pour des médecins qui
veulent partir de lettres de
recommandation les le plus inquiétant
c'est ce sont les meilleurs donc la
fuite
tous les médecins de mieux qualifier les
mieux formés qui sont les spécialistes
et sous spécialistes et des spécialistes
de loin qui font des actes difficile et
qui ont contribué et contribuent et
encore tout récemment à faire du liban
un pays de tourisme médical qui ce qui a
amené à la réputation de l'hôpital du
moyen-orient donc ce statut n'existe
plus ce statut et doit d'être récupérés
dans la situation actuelle le nombre
total de médecins qui a quitté le liban
jusqu'en octobre 2020 un an après le
soulèvement populaire était de 400
médecins
les chiffres se sont aggravées récemment
vu l'instabilité politique sécuritaire
et financière le canton près de trente
médecins qui quittent par semaine ce qui
a amené le chiffre global am il a au mad
max et ce n'est pas prêt de s'arrêter
et encore plus plus grave c'est que ces
médecins la quitte pour toujours ils
quittent ils plient bagages ils font
avec leur famille pour le pays d'accueil
des pays principaux de destination sont
la france les états unis le canada
pour la stabilité et la qualité de vie
qui a là bas mais aussi les pays arabes
les pays du golfe qui avant eux venaient
se soigner dans le liban et parfaire la
formation dans notre pays sont
maintenant la destination de nos
cerveaux qui vont rechercher la matrice
financier entre de stabilité qui
correspond plus à leurs ambitions que le
pays actuellement est là je sais que le
liban traverse plusieurs crises en
inédite on parle d'une crise politique
une crise sanitaire une crise économique
aujourd'hui la livre égyptienne la livre
libanaise pardon ne vaut pas grand chose
justement les salaires les salaires qui
sont convertis en dollars
c'est ça qui fait fuir en partie les
médecins les balais ou est ce que les
conditions actuellement de la crise
sanitaire font que vous êtes débordé
dans les hôpitaux et voilà certains sont
obligés de partir ces prix factorielle
comme vous dites il ya d'abord la crise
financière il ya aussi surtout le manque
de confiance dans l'establishment
politique l'absence de projet politique
l'absence de sécurité tant sur le plan
financier sur le plan d'avenir
il ya les médecins ne trouvent plus leur
avenir dit leurs ambitions se dessiner
dans ce pays et préfèrent chercher dans
l'avenir ailleurs c'est c'est très très
très grave parce que maintenant nous
sommes en train de traverser une crise
sanitaire aussi avec la le coc vite
qu'ils se développent et nous attendons
aussi une vague une nouvelle vague de
covile mais c'est tout que les médecins
qui partent sont les jeunes médecins qui
qui sont la tranche d'âge et entre 30 et
55 ans sont les deux ça sur lesquels
nous avons pâti l'avenir du liban et
maintenant ils vont partir dans des
dents d'autres horizons qui vont
profiter de leur talent la jeunesse
libérée ce qui est pourtant très
impliqué un don à la rue beaucoup de
manifestations
on le voit qui dénoncent justement le
pouvoir en place actuellement
on sait que jusqu'à maintenant le liban
n'est pas de gouvernement qu'est ce que
vous attendez qu est ce que vous espérez
c'est à dire que nous avons beaucoup
espéré avant maintenant les gens
commencent à perdre espoir
depuis quelques mois il ya des
négociations pour former un
un moment depuis des mois avant il y
avait aussi les contestations populaires
et sociales qui n'ont pas abouti à grand
chose
les choses s'étaient venise la situation
de se détériorer les gens résistent mais
à des gens qu'il peut plus résister
toutes les classes sociales toutes les
catégories sont touchées par ce
phénomène d'appauvrissement et de manque
de sécurité sociale et politique
une fuite des élites du liban qui est
catastrophique
alors c'est très difficile mais comment
voyez-vous l'avenir vous précisément
qu'est ce que vous allez faire c'est à
dire que l'idée de partir on joue notre
tout le temps tous les jours pour
l'instant sur pas personnellement
j'étais beaucoup de responsabilités dans
l'institution dans laquelle je travaille
donc mon départ n'est pas n'est pas
d'actualité
en tout cas merci beaucoup pour votre
témoignage neigé à 1000 hs je rappelle
que vous êtes chef de service de
réanimation cardiaque et directeur
médical de l'hôpital récent où il est au
chu à beyrouth